Gotta go back to Albuquerque. I know Albuquerque,
I think on Wednesday or some, dude,
I was in Albuquerque for two days and I w I was there. I flew in,
I had a whole day there. I did my, my, the meetings that I had to do.
And then I was done at like two or three and the rest of the day, I was like,
all right, cool. I worked out a little bit,
keep my back all mountainous. You know what I mean?
I did some chin-ups just to make sure the lats kept like a turtle shell.
I did some chest exercise to make sure that, you know what I mean?
I keep my Sikh cup and I did shoulders exercise, of course,
because I want to keep the documentary, I want to keep the documentarian happy.
Cause they're probably doing a documentary on my shoulders or some. So, uh,
I was in Albuquerque. And let me tell you something, man.
It was for one day and I was leaving the next day and bully,
is it boring? It's hot as.
I mean 11 o'clock. I landed and I, the day before, and I was like, Hey guys,
is there a place to eat or something? And they were like, no,
they didn't even like, think you were like, there's burger King. And I was like,
Hey, look at me. Do I look like,
I want to do I look like I need fast food right now at 11
look at me. And they were like, yeah, no, I mean, you do keep your back,
like a turtle. You know, it's like a turtle shell. And I saw a documentary crew,
like trying to be sneaky.
They're obviously trying to shoot your shoulders and we get it.
You should be wearing a bra. So I don't know. So I'm just, I,
so I went to a place in downtown Albuquerque
and I walked in, Oh, by the way, I was like, is there any, I was like, Oh,
I found a place on Yelp. I was like, it's open. And I went to the lobby,
the people at the lobby. And I was like, Hey guys.
So I found a place that's open. I was like, I just, you know, I, I guess,
cause I don't know the area is this area safe to go here? And they were like,
Oh yeah, it's fine. Of course it's totally safe. And I was like, okay, cool.
Got in the Uber. And then the Uber driver, no. He was like,
are you Krista? Leah? And I was like, yup. And he's like, Oh cool. No way.
I was like, Oh yeah. He's like, why are you on this place? I was like, Oh,
I was the only place open to eat. And he was like, Oh yeah,
there was someone shot seven people next door a
week ago. Hey,
that's safe. What's dangerous.
What was there a zombie? Yeah. Well there haven't been zombie attacks.
No, there hasn't been a zombie attack there. So yeah. Oh dude.
Seven people got shot. Ah,
that's the definition of danger. And I went there and I was like, really?
And he goes like, yeah. He's like, yeah. He's like, I know.
Cause I'm a crime scene investigator though. Uber driver said.
Well, I'm checked out.
Hey, to know what a guy driving you in.
Your Uber says, just so you know,
just so you know, just so you know, it could be the truest.
It could be truer than the sky is blue. Or I live in a house. Okay.
When an Uber driver says, whether it's true or not.
Cause you know, in the daytime, I'm a crime scene investigator.
You're just lying because I, huh.
Imagine what's his name? David Caruso in that show,
whatever the he is, where he puts his CSI,
where he puts his glasses on and then walks away like the illest alive do
David Caruso. Wow. You know, something's definitely true about David cruzo.
He never got his kicked that's you can tell that about David Caruso so much
just by the way he acts. Because if you got your handed to you,
you would never act that bad as that guy acts.
So bad-ass he acts like nobody ever ever said no,
or me up. I'm on the that guy.
And I'm not saying this cause of any like ill,
you know, opinion I have of him or anything.
But that guy technically needs his beat because you can't act like that.
But he acts like that. And he just, uh, he, you know, I mean some of the,
just look at some of this,
but imagine this imagine you're a crime scene investigator and then Uber by
night,
CSI David Caruso one-liners there we go. First when it comes up,
obviously because they're ridiculous. Horatio canes.
The fact that his name is Horacio came, you know,
sunglasses moments, just listening.
You got to drive by drive by Miami style.
And then, and then he puts his glasses on every time dude. It's so hilarious.
Question becomes. And Alex was the mob sent to draws to the crime scene
or sent to destroy.
[inaudible] always.
The beginning of the show, dude.
Both of these stories get up and run away. You do.
You've got something to hide.
[inaudible] listen. Um, I don't want you to worry about it. Alright,
Mr. Coleman, because I I'll be a memory.
Never got his kicked. Never does so many. You know what he does?
He he's a wow for sure.
David thinks he's a black belt in karate because he practiced all himself and
never got instructed on karate at all. He just did it,
worked on it in his room and he's like, I'm a blogger.
And he would tell somebody I'm a black belt. And it's because he thinks that he,
he, uh, did karate every day. And he's like, I've worked on it.
I'm a black belt too. He says to like jujitsu guys.
Maybe he took off or maybe you got taken for a ride.
Bad. You know the writer, what?
The writers wrote every script with only a shirt on no pants on
and their out on the chair and they never cleaned the chair.
And they other people use the chair and they didn't give a.
She, she came down to drink mojitos and catch some sun,
but it looks like something caught her,
made it up, made it up. That one man.
Ended up himself. He tells him to leave it blank.
He tells the writers to leave it blank, leave it blank. And then they go, okay.
He's like, I'll come up with it on the day. And then he himself goes
and walks out the room.
He died hours before this accident ever happened. So our accident
is not an accident at all.
Oh, dude.
Oh, you know, there's somebody on the crew that wants to lay him out.
And he's just, every time they shoot those, he's just like, God. One day,
I'm going to kick his.
Here we go. We gotta move quick.
Tide is rising and we have a sinking crime scene.
It's not looking too good on the contrary.
There's a chance this girl is alive. And we
find out that's not even one.
The writers were like, let's try and do it. So he can't do it.
And he still did it.
I won a bagel at the,
in a restaurant. So. And what will you be having his wife's just like,
I'll just have a cob salad. And what would you like?
I would like the breakfast sandwich.
No matter how you cut it, divorce sucks. Think
it's a killer.
Alex. Miami has a new breed of cream.
What are you going to do?
I'm going to get you the truth. Not even one, dude.
What is this song? It's the who? Right? What, what is it, dude? Wow.
I mean, that's so funny, dude. I love that. I wanna,
I gotta play that. that dude. I'm Horatio Keynes.
I don't give a the who, what? What's the song? Do you know who?
Oh yeah, it is.
Who.
You, I think it's that one. Right? But not, that's not. What's called, is it?
Is it? No, it's gotta be one of these. Hold on.
That one.
All right guys. You know, we get it. They did that song.
It's called. Who are you? Okay. I'm looking, I'm looking. I'm looking baby.
I'm what's that? That's what's called.
Won't get.
Yeah. That's it. Wow.
When did they start screaming though?
After this? After our first.
Whenever, yes.
It's time to head back. Yeah. We knew that one coming a mile away.
They're trying to get our attention. I don't know. He just got mine.
Alex, let, just now that's down to one
or his hauling us
a dead body can have that effect on
a few more words. Already.
Verdict is in Frank guilty as charged the jury's out.
Oh wow. That was a good one. Good. That was my favorite one. Wow.
Well they found more than that. Oh wow. Pretty big.
But very cool though. We've got, is that farm status? Either dead or dying.
Oh wow. That one was quick. It was on the moon.
He was on a move that one's bad kids are not gonna get away with murder.
Get away with murder.
Dude. My Uber driver doesn't do that.
You know? Imagine you,
I got in and there were other people in the car and I was like, what the?
Why are, who are these people? And he says,
you seemed to have ordered an Uber pool.
[inaudible] Oh man, I'm dying. Yo, what the were you going?
Well, it seemed, somebody has changed your location.
I'll be a memory. I felt wow, dude.
Oh my God, how come? You're asking me so many questions because you didn't
because you didn't click quiet preferred
dude. You're uh, you're just, it's fine. You're a Newburg driver.
But imagine this guy showing up, first of all,
dropping someone off a block away and then showing up to the crime scene
with, what do you call them?
What do you call those micro with the
Sherlock Holmes microscope we call I glad magnifying glass
yet. Ah.